So, let's assume for now that we have a perfect hash
function. That it distributes keys evenly across all the buckets. And then
the question is which of the following will leave the expected
look up time for a given keyword essentially unchanged. For the first
choice is we can double the number of keywords, without changing
the number of buckets. The second choice is we can keep the
number of keywords the same. But double the number of buckets.
The third choice is, we can double the number of keywords and
double the number of buckets. The fourth choice
is we can halve the number of keywords, keeping
the number of buckets the same. And the final
choice is we can have half as many keywords,
and half as many buckets. And the question
is, which of these five, and there could be
more than one that's correct, Will essentially leave the
time it takes to look up a keyword unchanged.